[Music]
if there's a multiverse where force
hammer isn't the most badass weapon
around I don't want to live in it the
hammer is called Mjolnir which sounds
like the name of a fearsome Norwegian
black metal outfit and it's tough enough
to knock out a rampaging hog anyone else
but my infatuation stops there because
Mjolnir is also the god of thunders
primary means of transportation and the
idea of hammer travel is as the Norse
would say idiotic excrement er in the
comics and movies Thor twirls Millner at
great speed generating enormous angular
momentum then he hurls it in the
direction he wants to travel and
instantly grabs it again thereby
hitching a ride on the deity flung
missile flagrant foul traveling in a
manner that violates the laws of physics
whoever's in charge of Aeronautics
fact-checking at Marvel you should know
that every time hammer travel happens
Isaac Newton spins in his grave and
generates plenty of angular momentum
while he's at it
look conservation of momentum dictates
that four shouldn't be able to change
direction once he's flying but according
to the comics he uses magic to control
his trajectory once he's launched that's
so why can't he just use magic to fly in
the first place he's using magic to
summon lightning and caused tornadoes
nice continuity jackass Guardians if
Marvel were serious about this they
stick to how four actually travels in
Norse mythology in a cart pulled by his
goats
tangra snore the tooth Nasher and penned
v Esther the tooth grinder whom force
slaughters every night for dinner and
resurrects the next morning think of
this cinematic potential for goat
devourer coming to theaters in 2016
Marvel Studios
I'll await my check why can't Hawkeye
just hitch a ride on his arrows let me
know a comic book crimes against physics
get your goat in the comments also
why doesn't Thor have a catchphrase is
it because stop hematite is already
taken suggest a catchphrase for Thor in
the comments
[Music]